على وجه ماء شط العرب يطفو احد اغلى يخوت
العالم منذ 20 عاما اليخت جانح في مياه
الحرب والاهمال التي اصابته بعد نهايه حكم
الرئيس العراقي الراحل صدام حسين 20 عاما
على الحرب الامريكيه في العراق حملت معها
الكثير من الاحداث كان منها غرق يختل
منصور الخاص بصدام حسين
رقيه بسنوات ونهبي كل ما فيه من اشياء
ثمينه اليوم اصبح هيكلا متهلكا يتوسط
الماء ولا يحمل الا بعض ذكريات من عهد
الرئيس الذي لم يستقله في يوم من الايام
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من البصره مراسله صباح العربيه
زينب الاجانب المشاط زينب يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك تاخذين اليوم تجربه فريده يعني نستكشف
معك اهلا بك نستشف معك صدام حسين الغارق
في شط العرب
زينب تسمعيني
نعم في الواقع انا اظهر اليوم نعم اسمعك
اسمعك فقط الرياح يعني حركت القارب الذي
يقف عليه المصور
انا اظهر اليوم من على احد اجزاء يخت
المنصور في شط العرب جنوبي البصره طبعا
كنا ننوي ان نقف على سطح هذا اليخت لكن
للاسف الرياح اليوم تجري على عكس ما نشتهي
طبعا هذا اليخت صنع في ثمانينيات القرن
الماضي في فنلندا وارسل الى العراق عام
1983 يبلغ طوله 121 متر
يعني وزنها يبلغ 7000 طن تقريبا طبعا هذا
اليخت يعد واحد من اهم واضخم اليخوت التي
كان يملكها صدام حسين والتي هي تقدر
بحوالي ثلاثه يخوض تقريبا هذا اليخت كان
يرسه في ميناء ام قصر حتى عام 2003 قرر
صدام حسين رساله الى ممرشط العرب في اذار
ثلاثه نعم طبعا خشيه على اليخت من القصف
الاميركي لكن للاسف الخطه الخطه فشلت
وتعرض القصف بعد ذلك في اذار 2003 اليخت
الى القصف على مدى ثلاث ايام متتاليه لكن
هذا القصف يعني لم يتسبب بغرق اليخت كما
ذكرت مفتشيه اثار البصره ما تسبب بغرق
اليخت هو سرقه المضخات الضخمه الموجوده في
محركات هذا اليخت والتي ادت الى حدوث ثقوب
كبيره جدا وتسربت المياه في اليخت فبدا
اليخت بالميلان تحديدا في يونيو 2003 طبعا
كما نشاهد اليخت اليوم يعني هو هيكل صدق
ومتهالك يتواجد في يعني يقف في منتصف شط
العرب وهو اليوم يعني مزار للسياح
والصيادين ايضا الحكومه المحليه في البصره
تنوي حسب ما يقال تفكيك هذا اليخت وتقسيمه
الى اجزاء وانتشاله من شط العرب لكن هذا
الامر يتطلب مبالغ كبيره جدا جدا نعم زينب
اول شغله اسمحي لي انه انا احييك يعني هذا
اللايف مميز جدا وجودك الان في البصره في
جنوب العراق وعلى هذا الهيكل الهيكل الذي
يعني يتحدث عن تاريخ ويتحدث عن حقبه زمنيه
وسياسيه في العراق الان انت تقفين على هذا
القارب وفي مكان خطر يعني نتمنى لك
السلامه وايضا للكاميرا مان وقطعتي
الساعات سفر من البصره حتى من بغداد حتى
تصل الى البصره نحييك اولا على هذا الامر
وايضا يعني رغم المواقف السياسيه اليوم من
قبل المشاهدين بحقبه صدام حسين الى انه لا
نستطيع ولا احد ينكر بان الان ما نشاهده
هذه الصور هي مشاهد فعلا يعني تستحق النظر
يعني مشاهد تعيد بنا الزمن الى الوراء
تساؤلات كثيره واليوم نحن يعني اتوقع زينب
باننا ننفرد بهكذا انواع من المباشر
بهكذا نوع من المباشر يعني كان في اخبار
مثلا بالوكالات وبالصحف فقط هم ينشرون صور
لهذا القارب الذي يطفو في شط العرب في
البصره ولكن عندما نتحدث عن هذا المباشر
اعتقد بانه صباح العربيه يعني انفرد قبل
غيره من المحطات في هكذا ظهور لو ايضا
تخبرين زينب بالنسبه للخطط يعني ماذا يمكن
ان يفعل يعني بدات بالحديث بانه سمعتي
معلومات فيما يتعلق بالخطط الحكوميه
للبصره كماذا سيفعل بهذا الهيكل وما مصيره
يعني اذا كان يطفو ونصف غارقا
نعم نادين يعني بالبدايه هذا اليخت يعني
يعتبره العراقيون فعلا جوهره ثمينه
متواجده في شط العرب المشكله ان الانتشار
اليخت من النهر يتطلب مبالغ ضخمه قد تصل
الى اكثر من المبالغ التي صرفت على يعني
صناعته فهذا ما يحول دون انتشاله بسهوله
لكن الحكومه المحليه تعمل على ذلك يعني
هنالك انباء يعني عن محاولات قريبه جدا
لتفكيك اليخت وانتشاله غير معلوم حتى الان
يعني ماذا يرمون يعني الفعل به بعد
انتشاله واخراجه من الشاطئ حاليا هذا
الامر غير معلوم لكن على بعد 500 متر من
هذا اليخت يتواجد يخت اخر لصدام حسين هو
وهي خط رئاسي اخر يعني هو يخت نسيم البصره
على بعد 500 متر من الان
ويعني هذا اليخت هو حاليا مركز لعلوم
البحار وهو ايضا يتضمن متحف لما كان
يتضمنه في السابق يعني لمقتنيات الرئيس
ونحن زينب نشكرك جزيل الشكر وايضا نشير
بانه اليوم عشرون عاما ايضا على الحرب في
العراق واسقاط نظام صدام حسين اليوم ايضا
هذه المشاهد وهذه الصور للقارب الغارق
الذي يطفو في شط العرب تتزامن ايضا مع
مرور 20 عاما لحرب العراق شكرا جزيلا لك
من البصره مراسله صباح العربيه زينب مشط